[Music]
but looking today I'll be talking about
happiness in life and in politics with
Robert havoc author and deputy premier
of the German state of
schleswig-holstein welcome to the
interview on DW mr. Harbach thank you
for taking the time to talk to me
they're gonna you come up in my dad I'm
and welcome to YouTube viewers my name
is Thomas Fox mr. Havok your party the
Greens almost chose you as its Lee
candidate for the general election this
autumn the upside is that you can carry
on surfing on the Baltic with your four
sons which would be difficult in Berlin
the sin-bin inflict kid so come on top
scene that's one way to see interesting
I would have liked to win all mine up to
help my party at this critically
important time and also to some extent
for my own sake I feel a greater need
than ever to take an active role in
politics certain so for me pretty design
some mission I'm doing that in
schleswig-holstein but would have liked
to work at the national level but yes I
do now have more time for surfing fury
of a kingdom idiom you have spent time
at home with your children and written
books together with your wife Andre
Apollo's that is quite unusual mukesh
how does it work riding together and why
does it work toy fifi fortunate as
painful to knit a sign of arson leaves
it was first and foremost about the kind
of life we wanted to lead not about
writing together we wanted a shared
profession and a family together so
writing was our way to shape a life
together in Sidon time it over fireman
limbs and Wharf in technical terms we
read our novels out loud to each other
your mind if we started by translating
poetry one of us would prepare a rough
draft and then read it to the other
verse with fixed measures don't fashion
language it took a number of bottles of
wine to find the right Rhymes and
rhythms and structure would work Muslim
distribution so when we wrote our own
long pieces of prose we built on that
cooperation there were spoken novels
which led to a distinctive style of our
own Paulo Quebec is a virtual author and
does not really exist it is more than
the sum of our two parts and something
different Gupta sis Mia diesel moons
I've either hetalia Oscar walls on
either side message done under this
niche to if some writers don't find any
readers unlike yourself you've received
awards and made money and also raised
your children at home what was that the
happiest period of your life that's
technically sits out in your name no
that's why I don't know about that the
present is also a happy time I can let
rip in my political life and though the
children are older we still have a very
close relationship it is different of
course it's free I don't sing them to
sleep anymore I have no regrets I am
happy being Who I am I respond it was an
incredibly intense time we spent
together both my wife and I accumulated
so much happiness and experience so much
togetherness that our batteries will
remain fully charged for many many years
some people miss out on their children's
childhood but not me those were 12
fantastic years we were able to make a
living with our writing and feed our
family and then came politics as the
next challenge commander song as moister
to our house for a longer annoying your
latest book is about your life and
politics and your ideas about politics
for you write that it's a tough business
and you claim the city who had to roll a
huge rock up a mountain and then have it
roll back down upon him over and over
again was a happy person must be done
Fung timber tribe why luckily he
mentioned we can bask in Nevada in
general people do not expect somebody to
come along and free them they all have
their own ideas there are laws and rules
and institutions the EU coalition's
Parliament's it's all about negotiations
I listen for Han Rome and we will
benefit ruling negotiations tomography
along Ababa Moses beyond as oh yes
grueling negotiations but you have to
welcome them Donald Trump says time for
empty talk is over now arrives the hour
of action there by abandoning the basis
for any social consensus and democracy
itself dialogue having to make an effort
to reach agreement hammering out a
common path that is what constitutes
society
us one you rarely get your way one
hundred percent we had to accept and
welcome compromise it is a challenge
that leads you to the next step hence
the comparison to Sisyphus punished by
the gods he has to roll a rock up a
mountain and see it roll back down again
for all eternity n back alone quotes one
group philosopher Camus said Sisyphus
affirms his fate and therefore must feel
happy as I do too i'm looking to get
scripting mentioned when the rock
reaches the peak it does not roll back
you just have to roll it up the next
mountain the great thing about a society
is that it's never completed does the
school's rtni negas a shaft z4 unfit
politicans you say the political world
ought to be optimistic and face reality
that can be hard here in
schleswig-holstein and across germany
people say they want a new eco-friendly
energy policy but don't want new power
lines in their backyard how do you
resolve such problems well even if
that's not the case in
schleswig-holstein in my modest sphere
of activity people may not want power
lines next door they accept them jagwar
support tests but they end up going past
somebody's backyard indian politicians
have to talk to people the difference
between my state and the national level
is that in schleswig-holstein we are
committed to the power line project we
don't outsource communications to a PR
foe we politicians go out and talk to
the people ourselves we hook them in the
eye and explain the project mr. like
I've spent many a night in crowded halls
listening to the cat calls but
eventually the protests ended and people
started to assume responsibility for the
power line now we're building it at
double the speed and it incorporates
good ideas that emerged locally of we're
more constructive and faster than before
it's a Sephora as a fun Giza means I
don't accept the cliche that people just
dig in their heels and say no doing
responsibility means making things
happen when people assume responsibility
they are empowered to get involved here
we are seeing what that can lead to come
on design used feminine voice oh I'm
like what about the bigger picture
europe is breaking up Russia and Turkey
are dismantling democracy and you
mentioned Donald Trump the u.s. is just
looking out for itself now it's everyone
for themselves how can you still be
optimistic it's diploma does just
collecting your guns our commitment and
consistency however my mind when the
refugees arrived in Germany we saw how
willing people were to help later
everything that was considered right and
good was depicted as wrong done our
water Alice was done that certainly does
not encourage people to be optimistic
about politics would you buy I know
optimization pretty key design mr.
Albert especially I believe
responsibility lies with the main
players they have to tell it like it is
say what the problems are and that
includes accepting hesitation and doubt
and admitting to not being sure about
things couldn't anything else is
implausible I nobody always knows the
right course of action only the
Chancellor and the Foreign Minister have
to pretend to know everything but nobody
believes them anyway still on basis of a
set of values these are the major
challenges and these are the values we
will not betray the streets are Odin
does if you remain true to that then
people might join that conviction by by
blatant and glorious we are seeing
people turn away from democracy in the
US and Europe in Poland not in Germany I
hope you get was it that had less to do
with issues of substance than with
people's despair when they are told
there is no alternative so there's no
proper debate about values I was its in
funda button but people lose confidence
in politics and look for alternatives
when there's no serious opposition in
sight they turn to any old half-baked
extremists you need a different kind of
politics analytic Kita's problem is no
constructivist but isn't there a deeper
problem the put into the potentates in
Turkey the US and Hungary didn't come to
power by means of elections that went
wrong or were not democratic they were
voted into office the normal way does
that not prove the democratic procedures
and democratic value
use do not always go hand in hand in
case you start just woman into somethin
missin mr. they do by necessity belong
together but not always yeah yes but
then they are no longer democracies if
freedom of the press is curtailed as in
turkey or if democratic institutions are
compromised as in Hungary or come under
attack as in Poland or when Trump issues
of frenzy of executive orders then they
are no longer functioning democracies
not in the true sense of the word
Democrat human presence me I'm finding
it is water the rule of law is a
precondition of democracy because
confidence in laws being respected and
that elected representatives will abide
by them to is essential to democracy for
other than fadumo party I can if you
look at China you might say capitalism
and democracy do not necessarily go
together but that is another story the
rule of law is central to democracy and
the struggle to uphold it determines
every democratic dispute is also know
that song in a rage flatlation dhamaka
and the free and fair vote in January by
Green Party members on who will lead the
party into the upcoming general election
you lost a chim oozed aamir a well-known
figure throughout germany by 76 votes
are you proud it was so tiny a margin
its east coast eroticism work it's all
be [ __ ] pan and i know i feel neither
proud nor disappointed it was an odd
outcome because many people
congratulated me but it did not feel
like a victory and i didn't win cham one
cup sniff Avantia is the lead candidate
and I congratulated him I will support
him in any way I can yes is a dose wit
some candy dad on Castillo dr. chunky
can give him come not disappointed right
no composed it was always more likely I
would lose than win so disappointment is
not the right word there was a brief
period of reorientation and that
included three or four days of
disorientation just please flight off by
a tiger on q-ball this katma dine havoc
ones the type is mr. Kovic our time is
almost up we like to end the interview
by asking our guests to complete three
sentences my role model as a politician
is what's up javi that's the top of the
chain
president and philosopher he was always
a bit of a hero both in what he wrote in
the way he lived the void us agus even
had fear Hans and add me and my mission
for each one mine forbid my role model
as a writer is yet Miramax Fort Knox
wish there was a time I thought him a
bit tacky but his way of seeing the
human animal is always so gripping
mentioned to clear truly code I've
stopped questioning its intellectual
validity I just find it great for me
novels such as homo Faber gantenbainne
and I'm not Stiller our guiding stars
light Danny for me lumi no happiness
means awkward are being able to let go
of things happiness means living a life
of freedom I saw its look I just kill
dipped if I had but Robert Robert I many
thanks thank you